i noticed something when i was uh so uh
when i was looking at some of these
fact-checking organizations
i was reading about i saw a website and
i forgot the name of it was and they
were saying like some outlandish claim
and i went there and i was reading about
it and i was like this story seems nuts
so i pulled up these fact-checking sites
you got like check your fact and like
you know know your fact or whatever and
lead stories
and i started reading about one of these
sites and it said
you know these stories are fake news
this is a conspiracy theory website
but one of the stories quoted like a
former cia official
and so i said how is that fake news it's
a quote for it's it's
it's a guy asking a cia official what do
you think about this thing
and they said yeah but the cia official
said crazy stuff and i'm like i don't
know
define crazy you know what i mean so
basically what happens is
you can get former intelligence
individuals to go on record and say
something but if it goes against
orthodoxy
then the the media machine is like that
must be fake news therefore it is
for example i'll give you another really
good example uh
joe biden was he wearing a wire did you
see this yes
okay they said fake news it was a crease
in his shirt and i said you saying it
was a crease
is as speculative as them saying it was
a wire how do you
know it was a crease in his shirt did
you inspect his lapel
no they just literally said oh these
people are crazy i think it was
a crease therefore you're all fake news
so you have two people arguing and
speculating with each other on the
internet
yet one of them is granted power to
actually inhibit
the spread of certain information that's
the current state of things
well that one was weird the whole joe
biden thing
um i thought that if whether that was a
crease or a wire i thought that that
wire was like a lav mic
yeah it's a microphone yeah that's what
i thought on his left sleeve it looked
like oh it was a little microphone no
that was a pattern no that was
no photoshop no apparently that was a
rosary bead
oh he was wearing he was wearing a
rosary for his uh
for bow well i know i did see the full
image but i thought in the image with
the rosary he just put the pen in his
sleeve when he was
not holding i mean which he he could
have but but apparently it was a rosary
but
either way whether it was a pen or a mic
or anything or even if there was a wire
here like what would be the significance
yeah because i don't care you couldn't
if he didn't have anything in his ear
anyway which which uh you know ifbs are
they go behind you and in the ear so
what what you know what you know what
they're saying they're saying that he
had implantable bone conduction
i'm like just like i believe he was
neural network just get out of here
he's got neural links yeah he's already
he's being remote controlled by elon
musk
that's gonna happen could you imagine
there's like hillary clinton hillary
clinton's in the back room with a remote
control and a microphone and she's like
controlling him and don't respond but no
but elon musk is like
you have to you have to press this
button here if you want him to move his
left hand
up no do it like you're doing it wrong
i'm trying to explain to you and then
she's like oh like this and then joe
and that's why joe stutters and stammers
she looks at the camera now
turn this knob to make him look at the
elon musk and neural link like i don't i
don't
usually fall for those conspiracy
theories like when they say that joe
biden is
uh reading from a teleprompter when he's
answering
questions from reporters like well or or
the one where um
where he was he was on james corden and
he and he's holding up pictures
and you're like see and reflection in
the picture there's a teleprompter it's
like well
but he's just talking about his kids
like who cares
like even if he was like in that in that
moment i don't care if he's reading from
a teleprompter
and he didn't sound like he was reading
from a teleprompter he wasn't talking
about policy but i don't understand the
teleprompter thing anyway
well because he has a he has a broadcast
camera set up in his
in his home no i just mean like who
cares well well
okay but see the the thing is there's
been other
uh there's there's been other
times where he's been speaking with like
a governor or something and it's
supposed to be a conversation
yeah yeah and and like an off-the-cuff
conversation
and then suddenly they'll he uses the
problem
he'll go and use a prompter and it's
like well that's deceptive
because it it literally says in the
title a conversation with governor so
and so
do you remember the thing where he like
pulls his hand to the side and starts
fanning upwards
yeah like that's a prompter he's saying
speed up because like i've used
before that's because he was he was
reading from something
right you know but but the fact that he
that
he uses it as a crutch for everything
like you just can't have a conver
like i'm reading from a teleprompter now
you wouldn't know this
no okay yeah it's all there everything
he's saying is pre-programmed by
it's all this is awesome all scripted
man
oh yeah people we rehearsed for hours to
get this right
takes time she's in the google doc right
now
like telling me what to say she's just
real time doing the prompter
i always got annoyed when when trump
would go on prompt because he speaks off
off prompt and he's real natural he's
loud he's and then he goes like this and
he starts talking like this and it's
like oh
he's boring trump again because he's on
the problem yeah there's there's
definitely teleprompter trump and
there's
off-the-cuff like fun trump yeah
correct and i everybody loves fun trump
and i love when he goes
everybody huh well yeah oh come on
come on all right well everybody who's
not completely triggered by trump
everyone who's normal everybody's normal
so because trump is
funny he's a hilarious funny guy like
back in the day the with the presidents
they they just didn't have a prompter
before elect
well not four lectures but before tv
before radio and stuff cue cards maybe
maybe they had cue cards maybe they had
like a speech in front of them yeah
they'd write down their speech did they
also just talk to people a lot more
frequently
yeah i'd imagine we need that again but
trump's doing that
yeah he kind of went go to a trump rally
max i've been to so many in
the past cycle it's like going and
watching stand-up i'm not even i'm not
i'm not even exaggerating no he's
self-aware he's he's an entertainer yeah
he's he's he's self-aware and he is
even self-deprecating when he like there
was the one point where he was like
these lights are making me orange
everybody laughed it's like we get it
dude he's self-aware he knows
yeah man it's it's like he's a funny guy
you saw
he he's definitely self-deprecating uh
like like for example the remember that
i can't remember what the phrases were
but there was an audio
uh file that sounded like one word to
some people and in other words
yeah and so the white house made a video
oh i remember that they made they made a
video of uh like was like kellyanne
conway
and um uh i think my pants and like a
whole bunch of the cabinet and they were
listening and they were saying it sounds
like this it sounds like this i don't
know it's definitely ani
but but it could be laurel like you know
if you persuaded me
and at the very end it had trump sitting
at his the resolute destiny he's like
he goes i hear koffee
and you know which is which is hilarious
like he is
he's not he he's not like i never said
kaffee
i know he rolled and never said it i
never typed it
well he does sometimes like lie about
weird things like he's like i never
called john mccain a loser it's like
you tweeted you called him i mean sir
well you know maybe he was i don't know
no i
i i look i have put but hold on i want
to clarify that
sorry trump called mccain a loser and
referenced him losing in 2008.
so i think he wasn't saying like what a
loser as a derogatory right
he wasn't kind of being like well he was
a loser because he lost which is an
insult but
either way like he said those words you
know but
he does kind of just sometimes you're
like bro we know you said it you know
yeah what are you doing just just just
roll with it
but you know what the funny thing about
that laurel yanny thing is yeah and also
there's the black black and blue or
golden white dress sure yeah
the most the funniest thing about the
whole thing is there's nothing
spectacular about that thing in any way
there is no psychological phenomenon you
know why that was happening
people have different phones so when you
listen to the word laurel with a phone
with no
subwoofer with a very like just like
just like a really high-pitched
microphone like a crappy phone
you have annie but if you had a good
phone it was expensive you had laurel
the same thing was true with the black
and gold dress and i'm sorry the black
and blue and the white and gold dress
depending on if you had the filters on
your phone like a blue filter or
whatever
you would see a shadowed white and gold
and if you're looking on a computer
you'd see something slightly different
and so all of these people are viewing
the same thing through different lenses
and different devices
and then being like you're wrong i know
for a fact it's this
how interesting and then it became like
but but think about that
and then think about jeremiah do you
remember when jim acosta
brutally just like beat that woman in
front of everyone i'm kidding i'm
kidding
do you remember when jim acosta was he
grabbed he like yanked the microphone
yeah yeah and all of a sudden there was
a laurel yanny phenomenon where i
actually had
this like high profile journalist hit me
up because i tweeted jim acosta clearly
like i can't remember exactly it's been
a long time but what i think happened
was she grabbed the mic and he was
pushing her hand away at the same time
so it
pulled her forward a little bit and then
i had someone message me like are you
seriously like believing that's what
happened can't you watch the video she
yanked it from him
and i'm like first of all even if she
did so what it's the white house's
microphone
right and jim acosta shouldn't be like
death gripping a microphone and refusing
to back down
but you can actually see what it looks
like happened is he's holding it
and then when she goes to grab it he
pushes her arm or she like she like
he tries to put it away push it away
which pushes her arm and then makes her
body move forward
something like that or his body i guess
i can't remember exactly what happened
but i was like
it could be very simple in that
everybody has a different device
with different resolutions with
different frame rates and different
people were
literally seeing different video
displays
well one thing the nick sandman thing
was like if you
knew he was just smiling because he was
nervous it was it looked different than
if you thought he was
getting into the dude's face that's
that's that's another really good
example
people's biases altered their perception
of what was even going on
dude all the time yep so donald like
donald trump you actually a really good
example is
there's this famous comic where it's a
camera there's like a camera guy filming
and then in the lens of the camera you
see someone shocked like screaming
and there's like someone holding a knife
but then the bigger picture is
someone running away and the other
person's holding the knife
so it's like the image was distorted by
how they framed it so it's a reference
to framing in media
so when you have nick sandman all the
people who hate trump
immediately were like we know exactly
what that is
and they didn't stop to think then and
so that's that they came out in the news
well they they get that they have to pay
out settlements because of it but i
think
yeah yeah they should pay more i'm so
sorry cnn oh
poor people did you see this my favorite
thing is uh
jim acosta tweeted the other day donald
trump finally condemns white supremacy
but then in 2017 the tweet from from
acosta where he's like donald trump
denounces white supremacy kkk i actually
raises it down
racism is evil congratulations thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast we do the show live
monday through friday at 8 p.m so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time